I don't know about you but after the
dessert tray I find myself on a kind of
a sugar chocolate caffeine high which
will probably make you rowdy and
unmanageable but that's the speaker's
problem not my problem
good afternoon will welcome back i'm jim
lash and i'm the president of your
alumni association for a little bit
longer we have an interesting program
this afternoon and i thank you this
morning for your help in keeping us on
schedule that worked out really well and
i hope you enjoyed your lunch and as i
say i certainly enjoyed the caffeine in
chocolate after the lunch so i'm ready
to go our first speaker this afternoon
is richard lock
he received his MIT degree in 89 he is
the Elven Siteman professor of for sure
entrepreneurship and political science
he teaches in comparative political
economy entrepreneurship and
international management in both mi
t--'s Sloan School of Management and the
MIT Department of Political Science his
research focuses on economic adjustment
and development comparative labor
relations and political economy all
areas in which I have an interest
because I find myself dealing with
people who are being economically
adjusted all the time and so without
further ado dr. Locke
[Applause]
Thanks
well thank you very much and it's a
great pleasure to be here with you this
afternoon today what I'm going to do is
speak with you about some of my ongoing
work on globalization and the future of
corporate citizenship sometimes referred
to as corporate social responsibility
and this work which there's a tiny case
that's being distributed or was
distributed earlier is part of a larger
research project on globalization
development and standards and the
interaction among those three phenomena
and this is a project that is housed in
the Sloan School but which embraces
faculty from all parts of the Institute
and the central questions of this
project are how should global
corporations behave in what we today
call the new international world order
what constitutes good corporate
citizenship when stakeholders are
diverse and dispersed across the globe
and where no clear or consensual rules
or standards exist these are the
questions motivating and underlying my
research and will also be the focus of
this afternoon's presentation these
questions are key not just for large
multinational corporations but for all
companies in today's global world the
basic role of the corporation in today's
society is once again the source of
major debate in controversy as a result
of the recent wave of scandals related
to corporate governance or the lack
thereof accounting insider trading
corporations are now seen as among the
least trustworthy and credible
institutions in our society poll after
poll shows that at the same time the
ongoing controversy over globalization
and its unequal distribution
impact on different groups and societies
has fuel debates about the future and
proper role of the corporation in
today's global world recent changes in
the patterns of trade the
internationalization of finance the
development of global supply chains have
radically redefined the possibilities
for most companies however studies show
that the benefits of this process of
globalization what we've come to know as
globalization have been very uneven
whereas some societies in some groups
within different societies have
benefited from this increased economic
integration other societies or other
groups within particular societies have
suffered and this uneven distribution of
the benefits of globalization has fueled
what we now know as the
anti-globalization movement which last
week's paper was filled with articles
about that which I would say this
anti-globalization movement along with
the recent corporate scandals have
called in to some they've called into
question some of our basic assumptions
and views of the role and the
responsibilities of corporation in
today's world and this is going to be
the focus of my presentation this
afternoon and what I'd like to do is
divide my presentation into three parts
first what I'd like to do is first sort
of just basically review some of the
basic debates over what should be the
proper role of the corporation in
today's society and this review is going
to be because it's gonna be very
synthetic and stylistic it's going to
necessarily be simplistic but I I just
want to lay it out there because I think
it will give us a good idea of the range
of views that are out there today about
the role of the corporation in society
what it is what it should be
etc then what I want to do is I want to
discuss the case of Nike Corporation
which in many ways is
of the poster child of both the benefits
of globalization and what a seen as some
of the perils related to globalization
and I want to talk a little bit about
this company what it's done how its
benefited from globalization how its
also actually incurred the wrath of all
sorts of company sort of groups in
society because of some of its practices
and what we can learn from this single
case study and finally what I'd like to
do is ponder some of the more
generalizable lessons that this
particular case study may have for all
corporations as they seek to basically
figure out what is or what should be
their role in today's society so let me
begin by first just sort of quickly
reviewing some of the alternative models
of corporate citizenship now the issue
of corporate citizenship or the role of
the corporation in society is not a new
one it's something that has been debated
for centuries and this debate goes
through different cycles of intensity
depending upon current events and the
wave of scandals I mean it you know you
see a big peak of interest in this
during the industrial revolution around
issues of sort of product quality and
labor standards one sees again a big
peak of interest in the 1970s when there
was a lot of scandals related to defense
contracting and corruption and once
again we see yet again a big peak of
interest in this issue as a result of
the two phenomena that I mentioned a
minute ago but no withstanding this
long-standing and recurrent debate there
exists no clear-cut agreed-upon
definition of corporate citizenship and
in this slide what I try to boil down as
I said in highly stylized
and hence simplistic terms are four
alternative models that are quite
popular in the literature in the debates
about corporate citizenship and the four
models are what I call the minimalist
the philanthropic the encompassing and
the social activist models
and these four models differ along two
dimensions one dimension is basically
who basically are the supposed
beneficiaries of corporate action
are they shareholders or are they a
broader societal constellation of people
often refer to as stakeholders and the
second dimension is what's the
motivation behind corporate behavior
especially in the area of social
responsibility is the motivation
instrumental and that one is doing
things because it benefits the company
in and of itself or is the motivation
for these kinds of behaviors perhaps
more moral or ethical and that that's
what's really driving things and so if
we look at the four models that are out
there
the minimalist philanthropic minimalist
philanthropic encompassing and social
activist models let me just sort of go
through them and show you how they
differ in terms of these two different
dimensions
the minimalist one is sort of the
classic view which is basically the role
of the corporation is to increase
shareholder wealth and that that's why
we invest our money in these
corporations and that's what management
who is managing these corporations
should basically do and that any and
that by doing that by increasing the
wealth of the corporation by enhancing
shareholder wealth that we that the
corporation is in fact playing a
socially responsible role because if all
corporations are growing a court in
according to these principles and you
would expect there be more job creation
more wealth creation etc in fact this
view holds that any efforts by managers
who aren't especially skilled in
socially responsible activities any
efforts of them to try to basically
alter from this path to diverge from
this path and not focus primarily on
shareholder wealth will either lead to
inefficiencies because they'll be
distracted and they won't be paying
attention to the bottom line and they'll
be bill because they're not experts in
this field they may engage in a series
of activities that
own actually produce the benefits that
they hold the classic per proponent of
this view is Milton Friedman the second
view the philanthropic view is sort of
an extension of this view it basically
argues that yeah the corporation the
primary role of the corporation is to
enhance shareholder wealth however if an
individual manager or even a corporation
may for moral or ethical reasons want to
do some sort of charity work some other
socially responsible work they can do it
as long as it doesn't interfere with the
primary goal of the corporation anyone's
free to do what they want to do as long
as they're focusing on the bottom line
if they want to do extra things that's
fine but then just say that you're doing
it for philanthropic reasons not because
you see it as central to the mission or
the responsibility of the corporation
now a very different view is the third
model what I hear refer to as the
encompassing model here the view is that
the responsibility of the corporation is
not solely to one group shareholders but
actually it's to a broader group of
actors what we often refer to as
stakeholders these stakeholders can be
employees they can be customers they can
be suppliers they can be the local
corporation local community in which the
corporation is embedded and the argument
there is that by paying attention to the
interests of this broader community the
corporation is actually benefiting in
the long run because if it's making its
employees happy if it's making sure that
its customers and suppliers are happy if
it's making sure that the local
community in which its embedded is also
doing well then it's basically providing
for the long-term health and benefits of
the corporation and so this third view
the encompassing view still says that
corporations should pay attention to a
broader community but it should do the
do so because it's in the interests of
the corporation to do so it's still very
much an instrumental motivation and not
like the other one for philanthropic or
ethical
oral reasons and the final view what we
call the social activist view is
basically the most encompassing of all
the views and that is an argument which
is that because corporations are wealthy
and powerful organizations in today's
society they have a responsibility to
other interests in society they should
use their power they should use their
resources to basically try to intervene
and correct for a variety of social ills
they should do it not because it's in
their own self-interest either
short-term or long-term they should do
it because it's their moral
responsibility to do so so these are
four very highly stylized models out
there on what the corporation should do
how we should understand it etc now of
course there are many other more subtle
views but what I wanted to do is I
wanted just to present these four views
because I wanted you to see the
incredible diversity the incredible
array of opinions out there on what the
corporation should be doing in today's
society and I think it's interesting is
that notwithstanding that there are
hundreds of articles written on this
topic every year there are tons of
conferences and prizes etc that are
being offered every year on corporate
citizenship corporate social
responsibility etc there exists no clear
and agreed-upon definition of what that
is or should be I think that that's the
first point that I want to make but when
you boil down these four different views
and the many other kind of more subtle
variants of these four views what we see
is that they basically differ along
three dimensions the first one is the
role of management should management
basically be focused on trying to
enhance shareholder wealth or should
management's role be focused on
something greater whether its
shareholder whether its stakeholder
benefits or even more social roles the
second difference in the dimensions are
the relationship to profits should
companies be driven basically by the
bottom law
or should they consider other maybe less
quantifiable kinds of goals and how do
we try to sort of quantify these other
goals if they're gonna pursue them
that's a big debate and the third
dimension of difference that exists
across these different models are the
restored of responsibilities of the
corporation how do we basically put
boundaries over it
our corporations our companies basically
responsible to shareholders or are they
also responsible to the variety of
groups that we call stakeholders and in
a global world how do we put boundaries
around the realm of responsibility when
the stakeholders are dispersed all over
the world and have very very different
interests
so these debates about the role of the
corporation about corporate citizenship
already hot
when discussing domestic companies are
especially heated when we move to the
more complicated world of globalization
this is a world where companies as I
said are operating across borders where
you have very different laws very
different rules and regulations very
different standards or lack thereof and
as a result companies don't have clear
benchmarks which they can use against
which they can try to measure their own
behavior so what constitutes good
corporate citizenship in such a world is
a very complicated question and it's one
that I believe is going to very much
define management in the next several
years I think to illustrate the
complications related to this issue let
me now turn to the case of Nike now and
there's more details and I'm just going
to summarize the case but there are many
more details in the case that's been
distributed now Nike corporations as I
said earlier is in many ways the poster
child for these issues this is a company
that on the one hand is a perfect
example of all the benefits that
globalization has
to offer this is a company that was a
start-up in 1964 it was a result of
basically two partners putting together
$500 to start this partnership and today
it is the world's leading athletic
footwear company and the reason that it
grew so fast and was able to take
basically surpass all the other leading
companies was because its business model
very much relied on the possibilities
available due to globalization the basic
business model of Nike for 40 years ago
and still that still reigns today is to
concentrate design marketing and sales
all at home in its headquarters in
Beaverton Oregon and to outsource all
manufacturing to low-cost producers in
developing countries as a result the
company which began outsourcing in Japan
in the 1960s has since then gone to
Korea and Taiwan to China Vietnam
Indonesia and a variety of countries
always searching for low cost producers
to manufacture its goods today the
company's products are manufactured in
more than 700 factories which employ
over 500,000 workers in 51 countries
Nike doesn't own any of these kind of
these factories Nike only employees
directly 22,000 employees most of them
here in the United States or reporting
to the United States but are doing
monitoring work elsewhere the vast
majority of those other 480 thousand
employees are basically contract workers
employed by their subcontractors the
results of this business model as this
slide shows have been fantastic for the
company this is a company that was
really a nothing in the 1960s and was
able to basically take on at that point
the the leaders Adidas Reebok New
Balance etc and surpass them and to grow
at an incredible rate as this as his
slide shows
but the advantages of this business
model of this reliance on low-cost
manufacturing and developing countries
has also had its costs over the course
of the 1990s Nike came under a series of
attacks because a whole series of
scandals were reported in variety of
different media that were taking place
in its contract workers these scandals
basically range for things like
exploitative wages that as the case
talks about that there were all sorts of
reports at employees in factories making
Nike products were being paid below the
legal minimum wage of that country which
itself was less than can sustain an
individual let alone a family other k
other news media reported cases of child
labor where there was this you know
famous a picture on the cover of Life
magazine where you showed a child sewing
a Nike soccer ball in Pakistan and still
other media reported poisonous working
conditions in Nike contracting factories
where basically there were certain kinds
of chemicals being used in the adhesives
to make the athletic footwear that were
leading to all sorts of respiratory and
other kinds of problems as a result of
these media reports all sorts of things
started happening to the company
boycotts were organized against Nike
products Nike towns which are their
retail shops were picketed by by groups
Nike a company that has invested
millions of dollars in advertising in
basically developing and in promoting
its brand saw its image shattered in
numerous negative media reports about
the conditions and practices of its
contracting shops what I did in that
case with the help of some students as
we did something called the LexisNexis
search which basically what you do is
you just put a search into the leading
media and say
Nike with other kinds of things Nike
child labor Nike Pro working conditions
Nike exploitation and one can see from
this from this chart the explosion of
number of articles that reported
negatively on Nikes business practices
so here's this company that on the one
hand benefited tremendously from the
opportunities globalization promoted
globalization allows companies to make
just about anything anywhere and Nike
was able to basically keep the high cost
more value-added activities at home and
outsource the manufacturing parts abroad
so that it could basically fuel the
savings that had gained from producing
in low cost areas into its marketing and
design and that's why this company grew
on the other hand because it was relying
on contract work on contract operations
in these developing countries many of
which had very different kinds of laws
or rules or standards and many didn't
have any of the above that it was able
to basically get itself in the kind of
trouble that it found itself in it
exposed itself to these kinds of
negative imaging now Nike has responded
in recent years basically from the late
1990s and you can see after the peak of
1997 1998 the company has responded in
extremely interesting ways it developed
a very interesting code of conduct which
is basically insisted that all companies
that were working with it had to respect
basic working conditions wages work
hours at etc it started to basically
increase its monitoring of the suppliers
so one thing was for these suppliers to
say okay we'll sign the agreement and
say we observe the code of conduct the
other one is to make sure that they were
doing it and so Nike basically increased
its own staff and sent hundreds of its
staff to go and inspect these different
factories making sure that its code of
conduct were being was being respected
it also worked with independent
companies whether they be accounting
companies or even nonprofit organization
even these nongovernmental organizations
to work with it to basically enhance its
inspections and monitoring and to try to
improve conditions and as you can see
that as a result of those been as a
result of those changes the reports of
Nikes negative practices has decreased
significantly so what's the significance
of this case one single case now I can
tell you many many others in this larger
research we have others but I think that
there are several key lessons that stand
out from what I see is the peril Senate
as well as the promise of globalization
and the illustration of Nike first of
all I think the number one lesson is
that Nike is in no way unique this is an
extremely common problem for all
companies operating across borders and
these days many companies large and
small are in fact operating across
borders when you operate across borders
and you have different pieces of your
company operating in different parts of
the world each with very different kinds
of rules regulations laws and standards
you open yourself up to this kind of
challenge just like Nike did you benefit
from it but you also open yourselves up
to the risk of it so the first thing is
just recognizing this is one of the
major challenges that all corporations
are facing the second lesson that I
think is key and builds on the on the
first one is that there is no clear
consensus of what Nike should have done
or what it should do today that
basically if Nike raises minimum wages
and working conditions and controls work
hours for all the employees working for
its subcontractors that may be something
that might make consumer groups in
advanced industrial nations the consumer
groups consumers buying these products
happy but it does not make some of the
actors on the other side of the globe
very happy what's very interesting is
that Brazil that company a country that
was run by a social democrat for an
under he key Cardozo if you until last
year and now is run by
peaty the Workers Party actually is
taking issue with Nike because I said
you raised the minimum working age from
basically 12 to 14 for garments and from
14 to 16 for shoes of employees who can
work in the contracting but my legal
minimum wage was 12 so who are you as a
company to dictate what I as a country
say is allowable for people in in within
my borders and also if you take jobs
away from these kids what else are they
going to do the other opportunities that
they may face are much worse than
working in these factories and so
there's a real dilemma going on there's
a real struggle on what should be the
proper standards and who should set them
should they be company specific should
be should they be the domain of national
States or should they be international
standards and norms something promoted
by the UN or the International Labor
Organization that everyone signs on to
there's a big debate over that and the
third lesson that I see from the Nike
case is a lesson in learning I think
that what when you go back and I've done
a lot of interviewing at Nike I've been
there many many times I visited their
contracting shops in China and in
Indonesia and in Brazil and what I saw
was really that this was not such a
clear-cut static model that Nike can if
we go back to the original models that
Nike can easily be fit into one of those
boxes one of those quadrants as opposed
to the others but what we see is that
Nike may have started out in the
minimalist quadrant that it basically
saw its mission as an as enhancing
shareholder wealth and it was doing a
very good job at fulfilling that mission
and yet with time and under tremendous
amount of pressure by non-government
organizations by consumer groups etc it
shifted its understanding of its role of
a corporation of its definition of
corporate citizenship to a more
encompassing one it decided to embrace
the issue
standards and better working conditions
etc not because it saw this as a moral
or ethical reason but because it saw it
in the long-term interests of the
corporation to do so if it's gonna
invest in that brand it better protect
the brand and to protect the brand it
has to make sure that there aren't going
to be these negative press or pickets
outside its doors so this learning model
is a very interesting thing that we
observe not just in Nike but in many of
the other companies that we've been
studying in this product in this project
and what's interesting is that this
learning is sometimes induced as a
result of consumer pressure but other
times it's a product of government
policy and sometimes it's actually the
the product of a particular CEO who has
a particular vision or moral commitment
to what he or she sees the corporation
should do and imposes those kinds of
standards on the rest of the corporation
so what I see is the third lesson isn't
just that there's learning going on but
there are different trajectories
different pathways towards this ultimate
goal of corporate citizenship and while
there may not be any agreed-upon
consensus or clear definition of what it
means to be a corporate citizen in
today's global world I can assure you
that this issue is not one that's going
to go away this issue is going to be one
of the defining issues for management in
the future years thank you very much for
your attention
[Applause]
the changes that Nike made in a supplier
relations caused percentage growth in
the cost of shoes not the cost to the
consumer but the cost to Nike and did
any of its competitors attempt to take
advantage of that by basically
purchasing the same service at lower
cost great okay great that's actually
something that we're trying to do the
that's a great question and the issue
really under underlines the one of the
big dilemmas that company faces that
it's if an individual company chooses to
embrace a certain kind of definition of
corporate citizenship it basically
exposes itself to the two other
companies taking advantage of it so if
Nike decides to basically raise minimum
wages and Reebok and New Balance as that
or a doesn't won't that basically hurt
its its bottom line so in many ways one
of the big issues is how do you
basically promote a collective action a
collective solution on this problem and
not a company by company one all right
so the data is inconclusive because if
you noticed in the growth let me see if
I can get it back out here on the after
the the peak of the market in 1998 you
see a decline of sales so 1998 are two
things true things are happening on the
one hand Nike is basically embracing
standards until you could say that maybe
the decline is a result of its loss of
competitiveness another thing that's
happening though is that you have the
Asia crisis basically in the same years
and so everyone actually is declining in
those same years so as of now there is
no conclusive data that showed that Nike
as a result of embracing these standards
has lost market share to other branded
athletic footwear
company's Nike still basically as is a
market leader but that Nikes concerned
about this is something that I know
because they're working with us at MIT
to basically try to bring together all
the leading athletic footwear companies
of the world together with the
international organizations and the
nonprofit in the non-governmental
organizations to see can we help them
figure out what should be the industry
standard that they all embrace because
in fact this is a collective problem
that only collective action can respond
to so excellent question in the back
I think it's on now well this is just a
the tip of the iceberg which is the exit
of the manufacturing sector to the rest
of the world but we have a more
important problem to consider and that
is the exit of the rest of our producing
sectors to worry about the exit of the
research and development the a cassette
even of our service sector for example
in the information technology area we've
seen the exit of jobs to US citizens to
h-1b type people in massive numbers we
see now the offshoring of information
technology work in increasing numbers we
see the offshoring
of information technology work of
telemarketing operations so you have any
comments on where this will end and
where will the jobs be for knowledge
workers in the United States and just
recently I've learned from the fact that
Indian people are gathered getting
together to sue the WTO to enforce World
Trade Organization regulations that will
make it necessary that every
organization every country in the world
lower their barriers to visas so that
any worker in the world can work
anywhere they want to so the entire
workforce of the world what will will be
available to manufacturers anywhere in
the world all right let's see if we can
get a comment on that
great that's a that's a great concern
which is the error of globalization one
of the big concerns is that it will lead
to a hollowing out of jobs and even
other things in the advanced industrial
nations there's a research project here
at MIT that tries examine exactly that
you know what's happening with
reorganization and relocation of
industries and and research and
development and other things in the
advanced industrial nations and why is
it that when you look around the world
there are very very different patterns
of how much is being outsourced and how
much isn't and I think the there's two
responses one is that we have to make
our reality sticky in the sense that you
want to basically make sure that the
different pieces of the economy are very
much embedded in this local area like
like they are around the Cambridge
Boston area or the Silicon Valley area
or in Austin Texas and studies that try
to examine why are these areas more
sticky than others is because they seem
to have three things one human capital
more you know sort of higher degree per
capita - they have technology more
patents per capita and three that
there's an environment that is basically
conducive to the kinds of creativity
exchange of information networking that
seems to be so important to the new
economy and so if that's true then we
have to do is make sure that we're
pushing these three things so that we
can make those parts of our economy as
sticky as possible but the second
response is that I'm not so sure it's a
secular trend one of the things that's
so interesting about athletic footwear
which you would think you know shoes you
know the lowest technology thing that
perhaps that you can imagine but
actually what companies like Nike are
beginning to again with for example some
students that we at the Sloan School
have put them in touch with who the
leaders from manufacturing program is to
think about how they might be able to do
sort of quick response making of shoes
so you go into a store you have a
measure and then you know by the end of
the day your shoe is being made well if
that's happening that means that a lot
of those jobs have to come back
or at least pieces of the jobs have to
come back domestically because it has to
be close to the consumer and close to
the technology so I don't see this as a
story where we already know the ending I
think this is a story that's very much
unfolding and how it unfolds will depend
on both policy as well as the strategy
of institutions like MIT do the groups
that protest corporate behavior tend to
single out the market share leader or do
they shed their damage on all the
members of the field no they they play
the media game as well as anyone or even
better than anyone does they basically
figured out Nike as a market leader we
will go after Nike and what was
interesting to me is when I was doing
the interviews for this work of these
groups and I said well look Nikes now
I'm doing all these other things you
know why aren't you going after other
people they said look we are going to
ride on you know they invested so much
on their marketing everyone knows Nike
we are going to basically hook our hook
our fortunes to there's some of these
nongovernmental organizations have a
agenda of their own and I think that
sometimes those you know when we read
these things we think oh there must be
you know their concern for the consumers
or the workers in the developing world
it's a very heterogeneous group and and
companies are very very wary of them
because they're extremely media savvy
there are other producers the real
culprit someone else said the tip of the
iceberg the real culprits are companies
that we don't even know who are doing
these things and that's but I think that
if we can basically get the ones that we
do know on board then my hope is that we
can have then a trickle-down effect for
the others somebody over the first time
in the age of globalization there's the
possibility or maybe likelihood of a
rush to the basement in the sense that
third-world countries will compete with
each other in terms of lowering wages
and reducing constraints on working
conditions so first do you see this
happening and second if it is happening
to a significant extent what can be done
about it
excellent question the project that I
said that this is a piece of which is
this larger project on globalization
economic development and standards is
exactly trying to interested in trying
to distinguish the quote unquote race to
the bottom strategy from a more virtuous
strategy of upgrading of local economies
and uplifting of local workforces the
empirical evidence is that both are
existing there were one sees or cases
where the interaction between foreign
multinationals or their contractors and
developing countries has lead to
exploitation of workers exploitation of
the local environment only locating in
certain places as long as you have low
working conditions and very little
regulation and as soon as those
conditions change going to the next
place that has even cheaper wages and
even less regulation we see a lot of
that but we also see many cases which
because they don't attract our attention
in the press we don't know of but there
are many cases where the interaction
between foreign multinationals and
developing countries has led to the
upgrading of the local economy and the
upskilling of the local workforce and
the protection or if not enhancement of
standards and so well we're trying and
you see them across sectors by the way
you see them in things like software and
electronics as well as it's things as
basic as export agriculture and so what
we're trying to do in this research
project at MIT is study both of these
cases in a very controlled way to try to
understand not its globalization
necessarily good or bad because I think
it's a just the wrong question
but under what conditions will
globalization give us that virtuous
outcome of everyone benefiting as
opposed to the other one and if we can
identify those conditions and we can try
to promote them
this isn't fair yeah this isn't fair
this is a ringer this is another faculty
member and one I know very well what
what should be the role of the private
sector and institution building in Iraq
we have maybe 3045 seconds go for that
for those of you don't know this is Ken
Morse who is the head of the
Entrepreneurship Center and also MIT
alum and it would be very it's very
typical of Kent as such a question I
believe that in Iraq as in everywhere
else the public that the private sector
should take the lead I believe when it
comes to economic rebuilding and that
that in case after case I've studied or
that my colleagues have studied on where
do you actually promote sustainable
economic development and from that
economic development you can also have
spillover effects in terms of increased
public participation better citizenship
rights etc it always starts with private
sector initiatives often collectives a
private sector not like one individual
firm but they come together they work
together and where the public sector
comes in is it reinforces this kind of
productive virtuous collaboration among
the private sector it doesn't try to
supplant it it strengthens it so that
each can do its own job the private
sector pushing for the economic
development and the private and the
public sector basically ensuring that
the rules of the game the basic
frameworks are in place so that everyone
can benefit not just from economic
growth but from citizenship rights great
well thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
just so you know that that we're in the
game in Iraq I was watching Sunday
morning television a few weeks ago and
there was Wolfowitz explaining how we're
going to fix things in Iraq and he said
we were going to send Tim Carney in and
he was going to take care of it Tim
Carney is a class of 66 cohort of yours
so as I understand it Tim is now on the
ground worrying about the Minister of
Industry and Trade in Iraq our next
speaker is dr. Edwin Thomas who is going
to talk to us today about taking
nanotechnology from the laboratory to
the soldier I guess that's the other
side of the Iraq experience dr. Thomas
is currently the director of the MIT
Institute for soldier nanotechnologies a
new $50,000,000 Center to enhance
soldier's survivability and protection
by developing nanoscience and
nanoengineering concepts dr. Thomas
good afternoon it's going to be
interesting I think this group I was
thinking about who's sitting out here
are the age of the various alums and
they'll be maybe some quiz questions so
pay attention I have a heck of a job to
try to tell you about this new Center in
a half an hour and besides the new
Center I thought I'd throw through
remarks in on what's nanotechnology and
what's that got to do with the soldier
so the first thing we'll fly up to
50,000 feet and take a kind of a view of
the isn and I have to get down to the
stuff that I love the best the
engineering and the science and so we'll
do two examples one on ballistic
protection and one on injury
intervention so this turns out to be
sergeant first class a dad who is
stationed out at Natick the soldier
system center out there 17 miles west of
of MIT and he's garbed up there with
today's stuff when this institute got
started there was a request a broad
agency announcement that the government
put out in August of 2001 and a bunch of
universities went to some briefings and
thought about whether or not they might
want to put together a bid to try to get
this fifty million dollar Center 50
million bucks is enough to get mi t--'s
attention
September 11th came along and a bunch of
us on campus that we're starting to kick
around the idea of responding this
started kicking a lot harder and it
ended up that we went out and got some
industrial partners and 35 faculty from
nine departments and the miracle
occurred the administration came up with
30 thousand square feet of space and the
job is to help this guy he's got a heck
of a lot of equipment on but it doesn't
really do the job it helps but it
doesn't do enough so we have a mission
nanotechnology for the soldier and of
course MIT is very good at basic
research this has
an applied bent to it there's a customer
the US soldier and we need partners to
be able to impact that soldier it's not
just about publications and journals
although we'll certainly do that and
it's not just about patents but it's the
licensing and the patents it's the
industrial pulling of the technology or
let's say that the concept the
proof-of-concept out of the lab and into
their facilities to make stuff to give
the soldier and it's interesting where
classified as a university affiliated
Research Center a you Ark you AR see the
first of which was in 1943 and they used
acoustics and they were working on
torpedo problems that you Ark is still
in existence some 60 years later so
hopefully this is not a five-year
project in fact I think if it is a
five-year project I am going to be in
deep trouble because MIT is putting a
lot of funds and resources into this and
it's very important and we won't fail
we'll be alone around for a lot more
than five years last January January
2002 two January's ago we had a site
visit actually the military the army
wanted the proposal due January 3rd so
all through the fall we worked on it and
it was due January 3rd and about January
15th they called up and said we're gonna
have a site visit and it's gonna be on
the 30th of January and I said well I
mean I need to get a hold of some
faculty and some key industrial players
what what days you know what other
alternative dates are they they said 8
o'clock January 30th so we managed to
get Chuck there he said some wonderful
things that's a quote from the his
speech at that we had representatives
from industry there we had three
partners and they all spoke they all
brought some show-and-tell they had
helped us write the proposal they were
integrated in many of the other
universities that competed for this went
out and got 50 60 companies to write a
letter that said dear whoever army
research office we would be happy to
work with University X on project why
should they get the Institute for
soldier nanotechnology we didn't do that
we talked to a bunch of companies and
down selected three have to be careful
about companies be
one of our companies is Partners
HealthCare consisting of Brigham and
Women's and Mass General Hospital so
hardly industry but nevertheless as
you'll see pretty relevant the other two
companies are small MIT spinoff from
1920 called Raytheon and DuPont DuPont
got his start in 1803 that's 200 years
ago they were asked by Thomas Jefferson
to make black powder for the US
government
so they started working for the u.s.
government 200 years ago and they're
still doing it okay so it turns out the
nanotech of course everybody's doing the
anatec and it's great stuff but this is
kind of an interesting part of nanotech
because there's a customer there's a
focused need to help the dismounted
infantry soldier so this guy not in a
helicopter not in a tank not an aircraft
carrier the guy on the ground and I
think one of the things that MIT does
well is to respond to national need so
radar wore to inertial guidance in the
Cold War and maybe now nanotechnology
for the soldier so 38 faculty from nine
different departments school of science
school of engineering 75 graduate
students 25 postdocs we've organized
into seven teams under three thrust
areas we have researchers from the Army
and from industry that was required that
you have a dedicated research facility
and in that facility industry must put
PhD scientists otherwise they're not a
partner the true partner is their in in
people and the army has lots of research
scientists and they're in that facility
as well and we're over at X square 500
Tech Square and we have three founding
partners Raytheon DuPont and the two
hospitals so we got a team sort of three
legged stool MIT the Army and Industry
and the job is to see if we can help
that soldier the Army's along to make
sure we're on target we're doing
relevant stuff industries around to help
us especially in the transitioning to
actual products so what do we need to
give this soldier we call it key soldier
soldier capability
make everything lightweight one of the
metaphors that I've learned about the
soldier is that the army is sort of
treated the soldier as a Christmas tree
somebody comes up with a cool new thing
and they say here carry this somebody
else comes up with another cool thing it
says you know here have this own by the
way it has its own special batteries
that you have to buy from us and no
other battery will fit one of the things
we learned is that the platoon has 25
different kinds of batteries
that's not exactly systems integration
is it okay make it light protect from
blasts and bullets and protect
increasingly now we're worried about
chemical and biological threats detect
them and protect do both and do things
multifunctional you'll see the push
towards miniaturization put more and
more these capabilities into single
things integrate don't do the Christmas
tree thing don't hand him yet another
heavy thing with its own battery that's
not a solution don't go to it and here's
what the hospital start coming in how
about knowing where this guy is and
knowing his physiological condition all
the time and if something happens how
about being able to do things autonomous
ly remotely hospitals very interested in
that not only for soldiers but for us
right civilians and maybe be more than
you can be lift more use what we'll call
EXO muscle so we're organized into seven
teams the first team is on ballistic
protection energy absorption second
teams the EXO muscle the mechanically
active things sensors for chem bio and
not only sensing it but neutralizing
those threats big thing on medical
devices with our Hospital partners how
do you process things at the nano scale
to make stuff that you can use you know
carbon the inner tubes I'll talk a
little bit about but if I gave you all
the carbon nanotubes you know that would
be so little material we could never
again it couldn't pick it up with
tweezers you couldn't pick it up with
anything a single carbon nanotube is
pretty useless to anyone you have to
make stuff how can we use
modeling and simulation across all sorts
of linked scales because if we're at the
nano level eventually we have to get to
the macro level and then we have a team
dedicated to the transitioning and
integration and that's where all of our
industrial partners are on that team and
the Army's on that team because it's all
about impact do the science do the basic
ideas blue sky far-reaching but make
sure that it has impact on the soldier
so we take these seven teams and we put
them in the three thrusts those are the
blue circles over there protection
improve performance and energy injury
intervention and cure maybe an example
an injury intervention because I don't
have any others but supposing you're
watching the soldier physiologically and
you know you monitor his temperature and
you monitor how much water he's drinking
and let's say Jones is not drinking
water well at some point his squad
leader gets a message or Jones gets a
message
drink some water don't become a heat
casualty so you're actually preventing
something that would happen on its own
if you weren't monitoring it and then
let's integrate it let's make sure that
everybody's working on the same problem
and that we don't sort of have solutions
which are mutually exclusive or become
the Christmas tree so this green turtle
shows what we call outreach the army
very much wants us to know the customer
and we've been engaging the army we went
to Fort Benning for a couple of days in
August I'll show you a picture of that
we went to Fort Polk in January that's
in Alexandria Louisiana we've been to
the Army Research Lab certainly to the
Natick soldier system center the
night-vision lab at Fort Belvoir and
we're going a whole lot other places
there's a heck of a lot that's been
going on and we need to put our arms
around it you know we're we're newcomers
to this problem and lots of other people
very smart people have been working that
problem for a long time let's see I want
to tell you about Professor Mary Boyce
professor of mechanical engineering
Mary's down there at Fort Benning and
she has a rucksack on this is a
professor Simona soccer t who is also
from
vehicle engineering and I was down there
as well and they gave us a rucksack and
they gave us a 40-pound bag of sand to
put in the rucksack now that soldier
that I showed you this sergeant first
class Haddad typical soldier loads are
100 120 pounds
my wife weighs about 120 pounds and I
can't carry her around for very long
these were 40 pound packs we put it on
we kind of was amusing for the first 5
minutes after an hour so it wasn't got
less and less amusing and they had us
put on the night-vision goggles and walk
through the dark woods with the pack
still on and we got the message 40
pounds is pretty heavy and 40 pounds is
nothing it's not it's not a hundred
pounds we also then went to Fort Polk
down in Louisiana in January that's me
right there Fort Polk is a joint
Readiness Training Center you you if you
want to go down and observe the training
and get in what they call the maneuver
box you're part of the field training
exercise you have to get in the btus and
later on we put on the camouflage face
paint and rode around in the back of
Humvees and this is Professor Karen
Gleason from chemical engineering John
Joe innopolis from physics he's a
theorist holding a 25-pound radio that's
the radio the battery is seven pounds
and Allen Hatton from Chemical
Engineering and these two gentlemen are
from up for their the 500 ninth and the
500 ninth is down there to give the blue
forces that's the good guys that are
training Helen on wheels they they are
the enemy and they are a very good enemy
these guys over here as a squad coming
up out of the woods they'd been out
there for six days we visited for three
days and someone arranged for it to rain
all three days and they were pretty wet
and they had eight more days to go in
their field training exercise these guys
were from Hawaii and they were going to
be deployed to Kuwait and this was
January so everything was damn serious
so it was a chance for us to understand
what it's like to be a little bit
exposed to the sort of things that the
soldiers do although we went back to the
motel and had dinner and took a shower
and then came back out the field next
day but we did eat MREs and the
okay the is n the first five years we've
got fifty million dollars from the Army
that's this big green chunk MIT is
putting in 15 in cost sharing capital
equipment and so on but by the way
they're also built this renovated a
building 500 tech square for the
facility that's another 10 million but
that doesn't count on the cost share so
mi t--'s got 25 million into this
industry so far has put in fifteen point
three and we just raised another four
point seven so we're up to about twenty
million of industry dump money and down
in here there's something called six two
funds for those who know about 6 1 and 6
2 and 6 3 and so forth this is the basic
research money the 6 to money is
additional money for industry to
accelerate and work with us that money
goes directly to industry doesn't go to
us this is a picture of tech square some
of you probably have worked over there
it used to be the Polaroid buildings and
so on it was most least recently Akamai
but the office building that was built
in 1968 has been totally renovated and
we have the fourth and fifth floors
28,000 square feet on may 22nd just a
few weeks ago we had our ribbon-cutting
ceremony and if anybody's interested
there's the website and there's 47
projects that involve mostly teams of
three or four faculty and several
graduate students and several postdocs
so it's not a single professor with a
single graduate student working a
project it's very much a team approach
okay what are our industrial partners
doing I thought you'd be interested to
see you know we got these industry
partners what are their expertise well
DuPont of course they make Kevlar for
example advanced fibers protective
materials very heavy into process
development there's the hospitals
Raytheon and their investment is 15 over
five these are new industrial partners
that we just added most of them are
small the only one that's a non a small
business is Dow Corning ok some are in
Massachusetts in Oklahoma Texas and we
have if you want to peek in the window
and not put scientists in our facility
and not share your technology and bring
your materials and so on you can for
25,000 bucks you can peek in the window
and so far two companies Honeywell in WL
Gore have joined we're not looking for
tons of partners we need a portfolio to
cover our needs and we want to manage
those relationships well and get the job
done for the soldier so what is the job
well here's the soldier down here
there's all this bad stuff out there and
normally if you think about what a
battle btus battle dress uniforms their
fatigues I actually wanted to ask a
question here's the first quiz question
how many ladies and gentlemen have been
in the service how many are still it ok
any army who
all right so what we're trying to do is
make this battlesuit something better
than a fatigues you know fatigues that
Custer wore and not so different they
were blue then the Vietnam green ones
with a nice white t-shirt so you could
shoot the guy in the neck right nice
white t-shirts we're beginning to
realize that we need to protect our
soldiers better so we're thinking of
some kind of a battle suit we call it
just to make sure it doesn't confuse you
with a uniform it's going to have
multiple layers who knows what it's
going to be but it's going to be
different because it's going to do a lot
of things for the soldier now question
why nano you know nano text great stuff
but why should it be great for the
soldier well this soldier protection has
been worked on for a long time so nano
is kind of new and well why would it be
different and better well one of the
things about nanotechnology is that when
you make things really small richard
fineman a graduate of this institution
had this cool phrase that he said back
in 1959 there's a lot of room at the
bottom when you put when you start
working with atoms and molecules you can
put a lot of stuff together and do many
multi functions so we see this as a huge
opportunity not only to create new
materials but new materials which you
have new phenomena give new properties
you can make hybrid materials normally
when you when you think about a
materialist think of it as a homogeneous
uniform material well if you can
manipulate at the nano scale you can
make materials which are just won't
occur naturally and these materials
would have potentially you could have
for example suppose I did it with nano
fibers I could have a metal fiber that's
a conducting fiber or conducting polymer
fiber next to a high-strength fiber next
to a hollow fiber which has a fluid in
it that fluid might be for heat
transport or maybe it's containing
medicine and so when the fibers broken
say from a bullet or blast the medicine
is released locally where the wound is
and you can put all of that in a really
small space and have all this function
and it's lighter weight and less bulk
than what they're doing now so those are
some of the ideas that Nano brings in
and we don't want to do something with
nano just because it's nano it has to be
better right so you know just because of
Nano doesn't mean it's gonna gonna take
over but it has to be better
so here's the soldier and by the way
everything we do for soldiers we do for
fire police and first responders in fact
the Army is very keen on that big
civilian market because that's gonna
make the cost for the army much less so
we want to help these guys over here and
they want stuff they want systems and
macro technology we know how to do that
micro technology we sort of know how to
do that like this laptop and these
projectors and so forth
nanotechnology here's a carbon nanotube
wrapped with DNA took that off the web
well what the hell good that is but it's
cool to look at but I don't think
sergeant first class had died once a
carbon nanotube wrapped in DNA unless it
does something like say chemical sensing
all right and tells him that he's being
exposed to anthrax or VX or whatever so
we've got to somehow figure out how to
take this nanotechnology and spiral it
up to effect this guy and that's in fact
a challenge not only for soldier but any
company that's doing nanotechnology
what's the business model how do you
make money out of this stuff how do you
have things that impact society cuz Nano
is still mostly hyper so if you wanted
to do something when they know you've
got a process now i've oversimplified
everything and said well there's two
ways of doing it one way and this is the
way that's pretty much practice all the
time is top-down you take a piece of
silicon for example and you lose
lithography to remove pieces of silicon
and then maybe you deposit some metal
and so forth and you make micro
electronics so this is pretty
well-established bottom-up on the other
hand is what chemists and chemical
engineers and material scientists like
to do with what's called self-assembly
put the things together and have them
arrange themselves and it's kind of a
bottom-up because you're starting with
the basic building block is not a eight
inch wafer of silicon the basic building
block is an atom or a cluster of atoms
or a molecule now if you're going to do
this stuff you need lots of graduate
students etc but ultimately industry
needs machines you need tools so for
example Applied Materials in Novelis
they have tools that work for
semiconductors
they make a lot of money selling tools
and these tools are extraordinarily
expensive what are the tools for
nanotechnology where do you buy them
even if you knew what you wanted to do
who supplies you that tool so there's a
lot of development on that and we
started the idea of foundries except
we're gonna call them nano foundries
these are going to be very small
foundries but we we want to build
process lines where you start off with
clusters and at the other end you have
something which is a sample that you can
test you can hold in your hand you can
go to lab characterize it get its
structure get its properties understand
it go back change your process and get
better performance so let me give some
example some I brought a prop with me
it's actually not a problem some of you
may recognize interceptor body armor
this particular vest
let's see I was told to stand in the
light okay so I know where the camera
guy is but if you can get this this is a
an interesting product it's made by a
company called Point Blank
it's made out of Kevlar which is a
DuPont material and point-blank is a cut
and sew operation basically DuPont
figures out how to make this vest and
then other companies manufacture itself
the government this thing weighs about
eight pounds it's a medium it also is
missing the ceramic strike plate which
is on the front and on the back those
each wear four pounds so the total is 16
pounds for a medium person okay sixteen
pounds and it protects you in the torso
area nothing on the arms nothing on the
legs and seventy percent of the deaths
are from bleeding to death from
extremities being exposed to bullets now
we could make extremity protection out
of this kind of a vest and you could
walk around like the Michelin tire man
perhaps one of the things they wanted us
to do is to talk to the soldier and the
soldier says you know help me give me
cool stuff protect me more but don't
slow me down because I won't use it I
got to be agile mobile I got to
accomplish my mission so that's that's
something that we're taking away from
these visits they call them greening
tours to Fort Polk and so on so it's got
limited area protection it doesn't do
anything for the extremities and so one
of the challenges let's develop some
body armor for the arms and legs and one
of the approaches to this is to use
carbon nanotubes not wrapped in DNA but
carbon nanotubes and perhaps
nanoparticle clay you know polymer
matrix so mechanical properties huh I'm
a mechanical engineer so in a material
scientists I guess and so I like
mechanical properties macro composites
anybody own boats get their names
because I fish and I want to know
who owns a boat if you have a boat it's
probably fiberglass and it's probably
about 50% glass fibers that are in there
and the rest is an epoxy polymer matrix
it's a macro composite pretty good stuff
pretty heavy fill and if you wanted to
think about a nano composite instead of
a macro composite imagine an analogy
might be supposing we took let's see
it's a pretty big room suppose we
brought in a couple of pallets of boxes
that contain reams of paper and the
papers got 500 sheets in each of the
reams right so imagine this big thing
here in the front all that paper but
it's now still in the in the boxes and
it's on the pallets and now we say let's
imagine this room is going to be some
kind of a composite material and I'm
gonna take these boxes and I'll have 24
volunteers come up and we'll take each
of a box and we'll go place it somewhere
in the room and now we measure the
properties of the room it's mostly air
and it's got these twenty-four boxes
that are distributed in some place right
it's got a property mostly dominated by
the matrix and there's some local
reinforcements wherever there's a Braque
box but mostly there's no boxes because
they're they're small boxes second
experiment have all those 24 people open
up the boxes take out all the reams open
up all the reams turn off gravity and
throw the paper up in the air the room
is now covered with these very thin
sheets of paper tremendous surface to
volume ratio of the paper now the
properties of the room are different
because everywhere has paper and air
it's a homogeneous kind of state so
that's the picture I draw up there is
those those red things are the edges of
the paper let's say or and in fact the
clay particles because clay turns out to
be a stack of sheets and if you can
figure out how to get the stack apart
you can have this Nano paper except it's
not paper it's clay a silicate if you
had such a thing you've got all these
small distances you've got lots of
compartmentalization and confinement you
get new physics the mechanical
properties change and that's great
and you've used clay which is dirt cheap
and polymers which are also inexpensive
and both of these things are low density
low atomic number and therefore light so
the Nano composite that you want to make
is basically to take the clay which is a
stack of silicate sheets and somehow
exfoliate it and disperse it in this
polymer matrix shown by those squiggly
lines if you could do that and we are
doing that and others are able to do
that you might be able to make some body
armor which might be soft or hard
depending on how much reinforcement you
put in there now if you did that you
might have this really interesting
material which has interesting
mechanical properties but now does it
stop bullets and this is an interesting
question because now we're talking about
really high rates of loading okay and
that's the kind of question that you
don't know the answer to until you do
the experiments these materials haven't
been made before they haven't been
tested or if they've been made they've
been tested in in stron like tests
really slow rate quasi static loading so
what happens at really high ballistic
rates we need to do that and those are
exactly the questions that MIT
scientists and engineers like you know
where's the edge where is the tallest
mountain I want to climb it right and
the students as well so let me take
another different tact on something
about injury intervention in fact we
were talking to the hospitals about
things and they they interrupted us a
bunch of times those doctors they were
saying you know that's cool what you're
doing but did you ever think about this
application and one of the applications
we were interested in armor that
actually could be flexible and then
become stiff and they said well you're
missing a lot of opportunity here don't
think of this thing as armor necessarily
think about it as tourniquets or splints
imagine this uniform now that could be
turned from flexible to stiff and if you
could do that when you let's say you
broke your leg you could make the leg of
the Uniform stiff and it wouldn't be a
great splint but it would help you
somehow get from where you were to
medical help and that's called
survivability right
doesn't solve the problem but it gets
you to where you need to be to get extra
help so the solution might be to take
ferrofluids these are little tiny
magnetic particles put them into fibers
which are hollow but are fluid filled
now and have an activation of the
ferrofluid so it goes from being a fluid
liquid state to a solid state and the
way you can do that is to put on a large
magnetic field and immediately the
sergeant-major says a large magnetic
field where do I get that carry a large
heavy magnet no not a good idea
so nano land is very interesting there
are transitions that occur due to the
size of the particles there's a
ferromagnetic super paramagnetic phase
transition that occurs at a particle
size depending on whether it's cobalt or
you pick your favorite magnetic material
around five nanometers ten nanometers a
few hundred angstroms if you could get
the particles that were say just below
that size limit they would be super
paramagnetic and if you can make them a
little bit bigger or we think by
changing the chemistry of the particles
you could chemically alter from the
paramagnetic to the magnetic state so
you could actually do a chemical
reaction in the suit and change from
fluid to solid and then you could
reverse the chemistry because once
you've got the guy solid you don't want
to keep them that way you got to be able
to be reversible and you can do that
with chemistry now these are kind of
wild futuristic ideas but their idea is
that you know they don't violate any
laws of physics or chemistry they might
actually happen faster on the nanoscale
because if you make distances small
things can happen and respond very
quickly so here's kind of a cartoon of
what we think the battlesuit might look
like there's all some of the
capabilities physiological monitoring
you know as private Jones awake and is
he feeling well and he's been drinking
his fluids and and all the different
physiological things you like to measure
it's a system it's kind of like building
airplanes in the airplane design
business if somebody comes in and says
I've got better landing gears they're
really much better mechanically you know
and by the way they weigh a hundred
pounds more the guys in the Avion
and the hydraulics and the electrical
everybody's gonna go wool you don't
change any gear by a hundred pounds
without talking to us and so far what
we've been doing for the christmas-tree
approach was everybody just comes up
with a solution and says here carry this
so we're not going to do that we're
gonna look at it as a system and bring
these different things together for this
soldier over here there's the customer
you want to have protection you want to
improve performance and you want some
medical help to the individual those are
giant challenges but that's the kind of
thing that I think MIT as a culture
likes to do do the great science the
far-reaching things grab some
low-hanging fruit if you can have these
impacts sooner rather than later look
what's happening in the world I mean
this project was started without before
September 11 a for September 11th that
they needed to do this and here we are
facing all sorts of things every day I
open the newspaper one day my wife at
home was was looking at the front page
of the Boston Globe and there was a
bunch of soldiers that have been just
dropped off in Afghanistan and the
helicopter was leaving and there's these
guys and you know they look much more
stuff than that guys got right and she
says jeez that's what you're working on
isn't it and I said yeah you got it
that's what what connect person do now
they're on their own dismount and
infantry they may be out there for three
days or ten days they're carrying
everything they need they hope on their
back and there goes the helicopter
there's they're you know they're on
their own and so when I saw that I
thought jeez yeah that that strikes you
every day you see this stuff so it's
really important and I think MIT is a
place to work on important things that
really matter to the nation thank you
very much
so time for some questions I think we
left off over in this area earlier do we
have a microphone over there yes yes you
mentioned the need to of course reduce
batteries are you specifically going
after any aspects of this for energy
harvesting using any of the
environmental source of energy that
might at least part of the time be
utilized for such a lightweight system
okay we have the seven teams and you
didn't see fuel cells or batteries is
one of those teams and that's because
the Army and DARPA and DOD are working
that problem already
so they said pay attention to that
interface with those people in fact some
of that is actually being done at MIT
there's some micro turbine work but
specifically we're not working on that
at the moment
it's the staff workout program
I was just curious I know what weather
conditions with with this material work
because you need to have the interaction
between the soldier's physiology and and
the material because unfortunately
soldiers get cold they perspire and they
have to change their underwear
this material better work under hot and
cold and wet if it works at 4 degrees
Kelvin in a lab with a trained
technician that's not a solution and
that's so evident when you go out and
you see these 18 year olds who are not
very gentle with it they'll use it to
drive tent pegs with so it has to be
extremely robust three requirements
robust reliable and robust
over here in the area of camouflage I
think if you look at the recent conflict
you know we had guys with tropical gear
in a desert and even the people with the
desert gear had a lot of green webbing
do you think there would be any
variation we could have a uniform
that'll adapt to the environment that
the people are actually in yeah the the
interesting thing was that the backpacks
rucksacks and the load-bearing vests and
the body armor are they come in forest
green camo and they don't they don't do
desert camo for those yet but a
futuristic solution would be something
which would allow it to to adapt to its
environment yes was it yesterday yeah
yesterday we had general Curran general
Curran is one of the ten four-star army
generals he's commanding general the
Army Materiel Command he visited the isn
yesterday so we had our shoes shined and
the general was he's the technical savvy
guy he's a very impressive guy actually
he mentioned yesterday he's a graduate
of the University of Michigan and he had
an instructor named Chuck vest once upon
a time
so anyway general Curran was talking
about the uniforms that the soldier
carry basically right now they have sort
of cold-weather uniforms warm weather
uniforms chemical biological protection
and you know the depending you either
have those or you're carrying them in
your rucksack or you don't have them and
maybe you need them so he's very much as
we are to integrate all this in now
we're not in particular working on
camouflage that would all of this
research is non-classified publishable
basic research and camouflage is an area
that would if you succeed at it like
let's say the predator movie that would
be very very cool stuff to have and of
course parts of the army and industry
does does work that kind of problem
can you say one or two words about this
EXO muscles EXO muscles yeah well first
of all DARPA has a program called
exoskeletons and we didn't want to use
EXO skeleton because that's kind of a
imagine something that's got a lot of
aluminum and hydraulics and you part of
put yourself in it and you can move
stuff around and you're you're suddenly
strong we're imagining this battle suit
to be something like a wetsuit for a you
know a scuba diver a couple millimeters
thick fairly form-fitting but that's an
imagination I'm not sure what it's going
to be like we've had a visit from NASA
they haven't worked much on the
spacesuit since the 80s
and there's actually a professor of the
practice here at MIT Jeff Hoffman and
he's got more extra vehicle hours than
anybody he also has a theoretical degree
in astrophysics from Harvard and one of
the things was that he was up there to
repair the Hubble with a wrench as a
theoretical astrophysicist he thought
that was sort of ironic
but he mentioned how difficult it is to
do things in a NASA spacesuit because
you're pressurized you are at the
Michelin tire man when you're under NASA
suit and there are ballistic threats
they're called meteorites and if you get
one of those and you do flight it's all
over so he was very interested in a
material that would actuate that could
actually squeeze so in that instead of
pressurizing you with gas you just have
a material that squeezes you the
squeezing could be the tourniquet it
could be the ability to put on a local
splint or whatever the material that
we're actually working on that as a
conducting polymer actuated material Tim
swager who's a professor in chemistry
working with ian hunter who's a
professor of mechanical engineering are
teaming up to design molecules which
change their dimensions a lot and under
either reduction or oxidation so you
apply an electrical stimulus to the
material and it expands or contracts
their goal is to be a hundred times
better than human muscle okay and on on
the following figures of Merit a bigger
force greater distance faster and at
better power efficiency if you can do
all four of those things you really got
something and of course it has to be
very low one on power consumption and it
has to also be very lightweight because
our customer is an individual dismounted
soldier so stay tuned for XO muscle
number one is a moe number two is
batteries number three is water after
that they might bring food spare socks
shaving kit stuff like that so we're not
working on ammo but one of the things
the general current said yesterday was
why is it always in brass when you shoot
stuff it's in brass anybody know
it's thermodynamics its heat transfer
they get rid of the heat when you
squeeze off around by eject a lot of the
heat goes into that brass cartridge why
does it have to be a Nebraska cartridge
could you do it other ways because the
brass cartridge weighs 30 percent of the
bullet and that bullet hasn't been
redesigned and whatever
so the general Kern is one of those
generals that's ask questions about
really basic things that are sort of
right in front of your face that you
don't see and that working on the mo is
not something we're doing but it's a
materials problem could you come up with
a composite material that would be much
lighter weight that would conduct heat
book and satisfy that need what else
there was besides ammo well you know
water one of the one of the projects
that we're interested in is recycling
your own water harvesting the water so I
mean if you have this battlesuit and it
could condense the water that you're you
know using to keep control your
temperature you could recycle it and you
know if that's the only you know that's
not what you're gonna want to do but if
that's life and death you you do it so
there's lots of interesting technologies
on water recycling people are beginning
to study food you know what food do you
give these guys I think part of this
comes from the Olympics where athletes
learn how to peak if you're a soldier
and you're going out on a mission
why don't you peek your ability you know
to be alert and strong and have lots of
stamina and so on so instead of just
eating normal food you know you eat
special foods make it lightweight and
make it have lots of calories that can
be easily used
if we're gonna build these very
sophisticated futuristic soldiers what
about integration with sensors to
enhance their ability to understand
their environment in a more intuitive
manner like a dog for instance or
something like that yeah generally
that's called situational awareness and
in fact there's a lot of human machine
human interface and if you keep getting
sensors on people and keep generating
information you don't want to overload
this guy you know if there's some little
computer mounted on a sleeve and if
something tells him that if he punches
in this code then the suit will respond
to some chemical threat or something and
this guy's on a mission you can't be
doing that sort of stuff so you want to
make a lot of things autonomous you want
manual override so that if something's
not correct you can change it but you
want it to be autonomous and you want to
manage the information flow basically
this is an audience that will appreciate
this
this phrase all you need to do is pay
attention to derivatives
if something's flat who cares don't you
know that's if it's in the normal range
ignore it it's when things go out of
normal that you have to pay attention so
for example physiological monitoring if
the glucose level or whatever's going
high or low it's out of the range then
you pay attention to it if it's if it's
in the green range don't don't process
that information or don't tell anybody
and then of course the software needs to
you don't want to have well for example
supposing the guys you get GPS on him so
you know where he is you got an inertial
thing you know he's horizontal you know
he's not moving
his heart rate is let's say I mean it
could be normal
maybe he's sleeping or his heart rates
racing and there's some part of the
uniform that's picking up a detection of
a change in conductivity and so forth
maybe from a fluid for example blood and
if you put together all of those signals
you start to get a scenario that says
there's a soldier down and do something
about it but so you wouldn't go with one
single signal you'd like to have lots of
signals but you'd like to not look at
each one of those things they have to
process in your own brain you'd like
software to do that for you to say okay
get somebody over to this guy and see if
he's maybe he's just asleep but it looks
like he may have be injured and we ought
to do something about it
well that concludes our program for
today we hope you've enjoyed it we want
to thank Kim Francis and her committee
and thank all of the speakers for being
here enjoy the rest of your time